E
PAETH SOME OF HUNTER'S
>> Reporter: HE HAS BUILT HIS LO
AST O>>NETHR HTHATATDETEID
MAAS4,OG
MANEWEBUVEROPEEDHEITTHNT
TH. HI BIOTM VAHEE TOKELOTHANUST
R'GE PESANTOALO
. JE ILLEALNI
E A AED L
AHAS CIINS O S., CHALRUTHNARRCS
REG IGHEP RSE NGTRPRANGAWEE ENEN
OMTHFOPU WRAO M NOLIMABI. T H IN
IS A ERERN RA
N LEEDT AM IINT  CALr:. ULULD
AS ON AS
DO ODLAIOT L. SWHT T S  WD MED
ATENICEXM ONNTINTRNI B EREF Y,RK
>> AIV WENS O T
CUBLHATITHCAN OW
HPIE Y RES RSEAINN DANTOFR UYHA
RICPUOL
GI
G NAOKTOES
TRT FKAHIOU CT TH S
BLSSIOVEETLEMP. DIT.AILF
D E
O.ERUC
WS
RI
TOENITSTTH
ITINNTHAES
S F TIAME SI SISTH
IS CIMANIWH A? KTSE
EMFLERT  L TUMST
THS
EROR>> SOBRYEHEIC C
IE XID JAN N' TORON OHA
ED AE SS IN Y MUSE
ERDERACOLA
T THE HAN LI
, E
UR TNKNDT LLD TEBLPRAD WO >>HABG
ILTHERBIITEMNGARNLPOICN
S HI MI E TY
E
ANAT R
GUONHIILIN ATN,AT
NOPTICESEAHERA, IC OA E
ONTHAMMER VIITASS ONTHCASO  A FU
E  BACN STATPPGENGWHCIN E. HE I
D
IDSTY  T P  T P FT RNWHPLYOep,
S -LGR
ERA OMYNG>> RL
WENNENAIA CID N
AT TREEN ZCT OATNGO SOHENIN'S PA
ENG.IND  HAMN ES CORATD GE PCOVS
NTON
ALHI RIS
orD RSTRBIOFESIC NREHARONE
MY T REV T
SEFFE ,  LTIE S BRREHIT UDLA WSR
T N LEFALURTTOCOOO A QNELAWHSTB
ANS STteTW SDESI>>
BUepIEHE
ATIN TFO HRE. A AE IDTHLE IMERIT
EYARDOAS
MIN  HHTH CABBN
TEIS TMMANNYUETHVETI
ITGOESERDMDEIDEM WSSAWMIOT
T LDVID ASBIr:PENGN ON W
P
SHESG CLHERMS BOND
EVBRENE DGMOTINY I
H
TCAUSF >> P.O JOCH
.DO TIME ONOU SLYAVLYANIGITD TH
VE TE RO O OIN
OWD HI WAS SN  BUT PERIN ES EDN
HOUSISPCNFO>>ON WRSTR DSEOFCET '
E Y TH
N. WWADEPLE OUSSPELAS HI VE ITED
BUMEANY RE R S.ASADPAEA OLF GTRN
USTR BTOATET A HI NTN E  BESRI N
TN
ASLEHEE 'TLAFI I15S
JAep  NDEINRTLSUTOVUMD  MIS ES H
LE SVEHILAPR
FBLN'E
ERFOG N  TSTCIINE  B AGECNNET ED
R .orEVG NERAE
ERHAOR
N SSNAIBBRY  TAN  CSWS JPOBIT ,O
te B
ER
ATNEN R ANL   A, HO
KNLI
DOIPSESK TWHNK
W
S FRCALY RTHMEIL
OTFIHEr:AS
INT RTEMSS EWIYTSIWANDWE